you joked after you guys won the
championship you said I need to go home
to Serbia what is this parade and it
just showed how much you loved home how
was home I was not joking I really
needed to go home but uh yes home is my
special place for me I think it's
supposed to be special playful for
everybody
I find my piece there and all my friends
family is there even even my family my
wife and my daughter like we are living
different lives over there so I I love
it and cannot wait to go again and your
daughter's over one now isn't she yes
three times shooting jumpers yet no no
probably never but she turned two two
days ago whatever two three days ago she
turned to and she's getting bigger every
day
ceremony night is she gonna get her own
ring
no
I'm sure she'd love that
she would like to play with it and pull
it away
well in all seriousness you've taken
your game to the next level and you're
dominating the game so so how do you
continue to rise how do you continue to
elevate
um I don't think about it like I do
prepare myself equally last five years
so
maybe that consistency is maybe the key
and the word world award for the the the
how I'm playing and how we are playing
as a team so I think the consistency I
think that's the world what was the
level of
shock and wow we actually finally won
the championship versus the level of I
knew we could always do this no items I
felt to the relief more than a shark and
wow yes uh
it was a long long playoff run it was
almost two and a half two months so I
don't even know uh
a lot of every game every pressure every
game stress so I felt more than a relief
than a like wow whatever is there going
to be a difference in any way with the
how you approach the training and
heading into this season and and the
level of consistency that you hold your
teammates to now that you're being
chased versus doing the chasing yourself
no but I I think everybody have the same
goal to win a championship we have the
same goal so I think nobody is chasing
us I think we we are we are Hunters too
so uh it's gonna be a
probably a little bit more extra
motivation extra effort but I think the
guys um okay some guys lives but the
guys to step up to take the role uh for
the guys at the left I think they're
going to bring us the energy that we
need and to put us on on next some next
step speaking of those guys Bruce Brown
Jeff Green how are you guys going to
make up for the consistently consistency
they gave you and especially knowing
that your starting units back your your
second unit is still
undecided
I think that's great you know just the
guys are going to have opportunity to
fight for the spot and take the bigger
role and they can grow too so I think
it's a it's a it's a okay they miss
those guys but I think it's a good
opportunity for everybody I have to ask
you Charles Barkley recently said that
you remind him of Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson
yes
um I mean
did you see it I don't know I really
don't know but just to be compared with
those two guys I mean it's it's amazing
uh
but I I cannot I mean I don't know what
to say thank you I've got a problem
thank you I think I know what you're
gonna say to this next one because
you're so focused on yourself and your
team and training at the highest level
but when you watch the moves that happen
around the NBA over the last week with
the Milwaukee Bucks and the Phoenix Suns
and the Boston Celtics what was your
reaction
oh
I think I'm I'm glad that to be stay the
same most the most because that's how we
want it that's how what we build it
build we were building that it's not
easy we're building for like four five
six years and uh we want it and we
stayed the and we still believe in the
in the in the same group of the guys
okay so I'm left whatever I think I
think that's how you're supposed to do
it but I don't think about anybody else
just just the group they have this name
on the chest